hi I'm Michael Moynihan with reason TV
and today we are talking with Sam L
savage the author of the flaw of
averages why we understand underestimate
risk in the face of uncertainty what is
the flaw of averages it's a series of
consistent mistakes we make by plugging
single numbers into a model where
there's really an uncertainty like
housing prices you know what are they
gonna be next year well they've been
going up three or four percent five
percent every year so let's just assume
they're gonna keep going up consider a
drunk wandering back and forth on a busy
highway you know traffic whizzing back
and forth suppose his average position
is the centerline of the highway then
the drunk at his average position would
be alive but on average he's dead it's
not a small effect and instead of a
wandering drunk we've got wandering
housing prices we've got wandering
demand for your new product we've got
wandering you know the duration of
getting this task done in a project all
these things are uncertain they're all
wandering around and if you nail them
down at their average positions then you
get grossly wrong results out the other
end
explain this this is the flaw of
averages the statistician crossing the
river right there's a very classic
example I didn't make this up
you've probably heard your statistics
class somewhere there's a statistician
who drowns while crossing a river that
is on average only three feet deep sure
it's like 12 feet in the middle and
there really has been a growing body of
work to solve these problems starting
with the Manhattan Project something
called Monte Carlo simulation and it in
effect bombard your model with a bunch
of random inputs and monitors the output
I like to think of Montecarlo simulation
is analogous to shaking a ladder before
you climb on it I'm what I hate to say I
don't think that there's anything
mathematically profound here perhaps
it's on the cutting edge of the mundane
but you know like the paperclip simple
idea but some
better than before you had a paperclip I
in the second chapter of the or a fourth
fourth chapter of the book you you say
that there are seven deadly sins of
averages correct we call them the seven
deadly sins at this point there are
eleven of them and Counting we decided
to call them the seven deadly sins it
said better rings exactly you just give
us an example of what what those sins
are and why why they're sins why we need
to purge the shore sure the family with
a one and a half children well it's true
the average family does have one and a
half children but you know find me that
family of planning for that family oh
okay we're in the we're in this
children's sock business let's see one
and a half children that takes three
socks so we'll sell socks in triples
instead of pairs for that average family
another one is is the egg basket that
comes from Benjamin Franklin don't put
all your eggs in one basket people
really need to understand that
understand the consequences of
diversification they go on and on and of
course are there there now 11 of them
and the twelfth deadly sin is assuming
they're only 11 because pretty soon
there will be more
is there any context in which in which
one comes out the other end thinking
that there is no context in which these
these averages are of any use is that a
wrong is that is that a mistake in
prison yes it is with certain kinds of
models linear models whatever the heck
that means yeah you're allowed to plug
averages in but that's like a little bit
like saying if a gun isn't loaded you
can look down its barrel the problem is
people don't know what linear means in
fact people can't tell whether guns are
loaded or not so you know a really good
idea is to not look down the barrel of a
gun I'd like to thank Sam L Savage who's
a fascinating new book the flaw of
average is why we underestimate risk in
the face of uncertainty is out now from
Wiley Sam thanks for joining you for
recent TV i'm michael morning
you